finding out what all these Obama
officials knew about the dossier when
they knew it is key now we've been
following these developments closely and
we will continue 20 us now with reaction
Fox News legal analyst Gregg Jarrett
former Trump campaign associate guy who
was spied on for a year based on
Hillary's dossier no dossier I'm sorry
if no dossier no application to spy on
you and through you the entire Trump
campaign great to be in the middle of it
isn't it completely out of control
strong yeah all right but Muller also
you're on the list of people that he's
asking for all these emails tax etc do
you know what the who the individual is
that they're talking about
well there's is it a guy that's been
melting down on TV tonight that's my
understanding you know after everything
I've been through these are this is a
small drop in the bucket so kind of
become pretty numb to it a long time ago
so Greg what's your take on the list and
what's fascinating about all of this to
me is I have my list of people that need
to answer questions one of the first
things you would do as a special counsel
would be to begin subpoenaing all of the
documents of texts and emails and other
communications and here we are ten
months later and you know Bob Muller is
just kind of getting into round two
doing that right about now yeah a little
late right yeah
and you know as for this guy sam nunn
Berg who is a peripheral figure in 2015
before he got fired from the Trump
campaign has been hauling off all day
long in a incredibly erratic sort of
meltdown way and making all kinds of
baseless accusations that he had a no
access to for example he said of Carter
page
he's a quarter-page colluded with the
Russians Carter's never even met Sam
nutburger talked to him well let's show
a little bit of number he was on fake
new CNN earlier tonight I think my name
came up at some point always good to be
talked about you know free airtime pre
promotion they're obsessed with us
anyway let's watch so Sam I have to ask
you one other thing yes ma'am and it's
an awkward question to ask but you know
I've been before you're sitting very
close to me yeah we talked earlier about
what people in the White House were
saying about you yeah
whether you you were you were drinking
or on drugs or whatever they loved what
had happened today talking to you yeah I
have smelled alcohol on your breath well
I had a drink you have another drink so
that's not know so I just because it is
the talk out there again I know it's
awkward let me just get give you the
question category let's go after the guy
that appears to be having a national
meltdown and then say oh I smell booze
on your breath not me I didn't have one
drink there's been a lot of people that
have been quite intoxicated for over a
year and a half now so there's nothing
nothing new here okay how are you going
to respond to Muller you know I am I've
been cooperative with anyone that wants
to talk to me I think the more the truth
gets out there the better so is there
anything you're hearing none berg says
that that resonates in your mind is
truth
I've was called by dozens of reporters
today and they were asking me for a
reaction I just said well ask him what
is where the facts are you know
everything should be based on facts and
unfortunately it's been pretty seldom
focused on that thus far and now we're
you talk about investigative creep now
we're looking into the Emirates now
we're we're looking into Sam Nunn Berg
and what they know about him and I'm
just where's the Trump Russia collusion
because even last week on the view you
know mr. TV himself Adam Schiff said
there is nothing he couldn't name any
evidence yeah he's finally backtracking
he was the driving force on every
television show he could get in front of
a camera on that said drunk Russian
collusion we're going to prove it
there's all kinds of compelling evidence
he said now he doesn't have a shred of
evidence three congressional committees
have investigated for a year and a half
not a scintilla of evidence of Trump
Russian collusion Bob Muller has been at
it for 10 months no evidence of
collusion you know it's about time that
he wrap this hoax up how many people are
you going to sue you know my main focus
right now is on the defamation front and
so that's moving along but it's similar
to the FISA Court right where they're
completely overloaded and there's
they're not able to list gonna be long
well I think I have some a lot of media
people very heavy hitters that I'm up
against and I also want $1 from the US
government if they own up to the
mistakes that they made well they
finally apologized to conservative
groups thank you both